This is a voiced consonant.
You can hear it at the beginning of the word joke,...
...in the middle of the word lodger,...
...at the end of the word bridge,...
...and at the beginning and end of the word judge.
Did you notice the shape of my mouth?
Judge.
Now let's practice.
Listen and repeat after me.
Joke.
Lodger.
Bridge.
Judge.
Okay.
You may find it difficult to hear the difference between the voiced sound...
...that you hear at the beginning of the word joke,...
...and its voiceless partner that you hear at the beginning of the word choke.
Listen carefully to hear the difference.
For each example, I'll say the word with the voiced sound first.
Joke.
Choke.
Junk.
Chunk.
Lunge.
Lunch.
Surge.
Search.
Now you try.
Listen and repeat.
Joke.
Choke.
Junk.
Chunk.
Lunge.
Lunch.
Surge.
Search.
Okay.